[Musik]
man muss reisen um zu lernen das sagte
schon mark twain ja und sommerzeit ist
reisezeit und gerade abseits von den
touristen farben gibt es viel zu
entdecken viel zu lernen
das haben sie sich einige
kunstschaffenden zu herzen genommen und
[Gelächter]
was hier noch sagen leute ohne kuh die
ergebnisse dieser reisen sind nun zu
sehen im kunstmuseum olten in der
ausstellung war schwach
applaus für die live chatten marinca li
[Applaus]
machen
[Musik]
die konzeptkünstlerin berichtet im
sanitas publikum in olten über ihrer
wanderung zwischen den documenta städten
kassel und athen wie die die täglich im
netz tut anders jahren hoch stettler war
wandert auch er doch eher koppelt sich
dabei ab von der welt er macht analoge
fotografie bei dieser italienreise je
eine pro tag
er sammelt fundstücke am wegesrand hält
seine beobachtungen und habe im reise
und das ist langsamkeit und verschwinde
die offenheit einfach daher am laufen
und laufen walken und dann unerwartet
und dann gleich interessant
[Musik]
auch sonja feldmeier reis langsam und
sucht dabei einen für die stimmige nord
[Musik]
kommt lecker und ich sind entgegen dann
die couch und sergej klammer spielen mit
dem reizthema
sie spielen mit eisenbahn und wohnwagen
und mit dem sujet der klassischen kunst
reise die von goethe und vielen anderen
überliefert
[Musik]
dafür muss in der künstler im süden
kreuz und kunst stahlwerke die zürcher
zum täter lehrer einmal umkehren und die
hand der wohnwagen oder kunst in
christes immer wieder mit verschiedenen
künstlern mit anderen ländern über ihre
kunst bereich und das innere bilder
bildcollagen wagens projekte die reise
mit eurer band oder kunst
[Musik]
lena maria thüring reflektiert auf ihren
reisen fremde arbeitswelt
[Musik]
für interessierte sich für die container
schifffahrt und die arbeiter die
beruflich tue diesen reisen gezwungen
sind ihr thema fremd und
selbstbestimmung wie der sommer und
winter geprägt und wie man die
entscheidung ganz anderes treibgut
orpheum er malt sich seine reisen aus
ist am liebsten den kampf unterwegs
beruf machen bilder wurde von
poster4city foto und filmmöglichkeit
geneigt die welt und welt gefühlt macht
oder eigene und das gleich mal vom
resultat dass erst eine luftig und der
doch langen der verteilung der
straßenpreis frau gestellt
[Musik]
die kunst des reisens
eine lache der inneren einstellung
na dann guten reife
[Musik]